tonight Tucker Carlson returned to
Twitter with a new show and in his show
he talked about what's going on in
Ukraine with these this uh this Dam that
exploded and who did it was it Ukraine
was it Russia now of course Western
media saying Russia did it Russia is
saying Ukraine did it and then there are
elements of the of the media in the
United States that are questioning who
did it saying we don't know for sure I
mean a lot of the corporate press
actually is saying both sides are
accusing each other but there are a lot
of people online who are saying it makes
more sense that it was Ukraine trying to
do it not Russia but typically honest
fog of War we don't know in response to
this Tucker is getting a warm welcome
from the corporate press who are ragging
on him calling calling him a conspiracy
theorist and uh I think generally
they're just freaking out because the
fact that he was able to take his show
to Twitter and get a substantial amount
of audience of market share shows they
are completely irrelevant and this is
only making it worse for them